hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter 6 of language truth and logic
a jair is going to provide criticisms of
three main classes of ethical theories
that were quite prevalent within ethics
in his time he views these as really the
the only main contenders that he has to
go against and we can call these the
subjectivist the utilitarian and
absolutist approaches in ethics so who
would we associate with those well you
know that later on wd Ross and his
intuitionist theory would fall into the
absolutist view I think Immanuel Kant
definitely does and air talks about him
the utilitarians of course would be
Bentham John Stuart Mill Henry Sidgwick
and even more to a certain extent and
then there was a whole bunch of
different subjectivist
out there in ethics at the time as well
most of whom are not very well known so
we don't have to talk about them and
heirs own view is that ultimately
fundamental ethical concepts are pseudo
concepts and they're unanalyzed ball in
terms of anything empirical they can't
be verified
they in some respect don't do anything
more than than convey our own moral
sentiments or preferences or desires or
our approval or disapproval and he
thinks that the other approaches and
ethics have gone wrong largely by
thinking that they're not dealing with
pseudo concepts or pseudo propositions
so he talks about this project of
reducing ethical or value statements and
terms to non ethical terms this is a
very common project not just in ethics
but in in metaphysics and in all sorts
of other language as well trying to
reduce things down to a set of basic
concepts that would all be on the same
level so air thinks that this is really
going to turn out to be impossible but
not for the reasons that for example the
absolutist will think and he's going to
examine each of these in term so he
tells us that this notion that ethical
terms can be reduced or translated into
non ethical terms whether statements of
ethical value can be translated into
statements of empirical fact that this
is a contention of two sets of ethical
philosophers those who are commonly
called subjectivist those who are known
as utilitarians so let's start with the
subjectivist first the subjectivist are
saying that ethical terms like right and
good can in fact be translated into
empirical concepts or statements and
what would they be translating them into
so he tells us that the rightness of
actions and the goodness of ends can be
translated for the subjectivist into
terms of the feelings of approval which
a certain person or group of people has
towards them
likewise disapproval as well for the the
bad or the wrong so this is saying
that there's really two variations here
there is the individualistic variation
which says that what I mean when I say
that something is good or right is that
I approve of it and there could be all
sorts of reasons why I approve of it if
we go a little bit deeper it could
because it Stokes my ego it could
because it satisfies my basic needs it
could be because I was brought up in
such a way that I think that this is you
know the way that I ought to approve and
disapprove will you go on and on and on
doesn't matter really at this level of
analysis all that it has to do is you
know revolve around approval by myself
it could also be the approval of the
group so it could be I'm a member of the
police department
I come in I get indoctrinated this is
the way that cops behave this is what
they approve of it doesn't necessarily
map on to what other people do but hey
that doesn't matter because I'm in this
group what is right or what is good is
what a group approves of and it could be
you know there could be another group
down the street who has you know very
different things very different
prioritizations or evaluations of these
sorts of things so righter good becomes
merely approval or disapproval now
err says that there's a problem with
this why he says we reject the
subjective as view that to call an
action right or a thing good is to say
that it is generally approved of why
because it's not self contradictory to
say to assert as his term that some
actions which are generally approved of
are not right or that some things which
are generally approved of are not good
insofar as we can stand back and take a
perspective that says yes yes I
understand that for example I'll take a
really silly example I understand that
for the most part everybody views
chewing gum in the classroom and
sticking it underneath the table as a
very small thing but it's still wrong
right it's it's it's a bad thing to do
we can use wrong or bad
so long as we can think that something
that's generally approved of could still
be wrong then you know there's a problem
with this subjectivist ethic in terms of
groups we might also use something like
you know where there's been some moral
progress you know in in most cultures
once they reach a certain level of
civilization they had something like
chattel slavery as an institution and
nowadays we view that as wrong and at
some points in time different peoples in
different places change that so we can
look at it say well that was morally
approved of by that group but it was
still wrong right and there were
individuals who brought that up and at
different points as well
Aristotle even mentioned some people
think slavery is unjust by its very
nature so there were some people even
back in that culture who said this is
this is wrong
so because it's not self contradictory
to think that some good some things that
are approved of and called good for that
reason are in fact bad or some things
that are approved of and called right
are in fact wrong we can't say that
feelings of approval defines goodness or
badness we can't reduce statements about
rightness or goodness to whether they
they satisfy certain people's desires or
feelings or anything like that same
thing goes for individuals too by the
way he says that we reject the
alternative subjective as view that a
person who asserts that a certain action
is right or a certain thing as wrong as
saying that he himself approves of it on
the ground that a person who confessed
that he sometimes approved of what was
bad or wrong would not be contradicting
himself so the very fact that we have
mutability when it comes to our moral
judgments I can say well I thought it
was the right thing to do at the time
but now I realize it was wrong I
approved of it but now you know I see
that it's bad that means that this can't
be the the right position what about
utilitarians one of the benefits of
utilitarianism is that it seems a bit
more objective utilitarianism broadly
speak
is a set of moral theories let's call
them that all say that the principle of
utility should be central that is that
we ought to act in such a way that from
the various options that we have in
front of us we select the one that will
produce the greatest positive outcomes
and the least negative outcomes and
utilitarians very often will measure
this in terms of pleasure quanta of
pleasure or happiness or satisfaction of
desires there's a number of different
ways that you can do this it arehere
talks about those three things and then
he also talks about here we go he says
we cannot agree that to call an action
right is to say that of all the actions
possible in the circumstances it would
cause would be likely to cause the
greatest happiness or the greatest
balance of pleasure pain or the greatest
balance of satisfied over/under satisfy
that desire or however you want to
define it because there were a number of
different utilitarian standpoints that
that could be taken and developed the
same problem that he pointed out with
respect to the subjectivist point of
view applies to the utilitarian point of
view he says it's not self contradictory
to say that some pleasant things are not
good or some bad things are to be
desired so we can't say the sentence X
is good as equivalent to X is pleasant
or to acts as desired and we also can
recognize that sometimes there there
could be situations in which we would
produce a great balance of pleasure over
pain or great balance of satisfy desires
over unsatisfied and yet we would say
that it's wrong or bad to do that that
thing so both of these are going to fail
on those grounds as providing
definitions of ethical terms and that is
trying to reduce ethical terms to non
ethical terms what about if we go to the
other extreme so err says there are some
people who realize that there you know
you you might not be able to reduce
ethical terms
to empirical concepts in which case what
are you doing with ethical terms who
says in admitting that normative ethical
concepts are irreducible to empirical
concepts we seem to be leaving the way
clear for the absolutist view of ethics
that is here's how he's defining that
the view that statements of value are
not controlled by observation but only
by a mysterious intellectual intuition I
sense that thing this is right and this
is wrong or this is good and this is bad
and you have to have that intuition as
well it says a feature of this theory is
that it makes statements of value
unverifiable this is going to be a
problem right he says what seems
intuitively certain to one person may
seem doubtful or even false to another
so this is a initial problem with the
theory but you might say ok that's fine
we do have different standpoints not
everybody gets it as we would say not
everybody has that same gut reaction but
could we provide some criteria you know
if somebody doesn't get it can we show
them something that will help them get
it maybe jog their memory and ear says
well no he says unless it's possible to
provide some criterion by which one may
decide between conflicting intuitions a
meal mere appeal to intuition is
worthless as a test of a propositions
validity we can't give any criterion
some more or less claim to settle the
matter by saying that they know that
their own moral judgments are correct
but he says this is a you know purely
psychological interest and doesn't prove
the validity of any moral judgment
because the other people on the other
side can equally say well I know I'm
convinced I have this gut feeling that
this is the right thing to do here's my
duty this is what you should be doing or
refraining from doing it's not actually
going to provide us with any sort of
ethics that we can rely upon it does you
know not hold the the ethical statements
to be reduced
both to non ethical terms but it doesn't
actually tell us what those ethical
terms are supposed to mean so he goes on
and he says that really what this does
this comes down to is a position that a
person can hold but other people can't
take on air thinks that the solution to
this is in recognizing that ethical
statements are not verifiable in any
sense and cannot be reduced either to
mere gut intuitions or intellectual
intuitions or to some other set of
empirical concepts that we can
manipulate we need to recognize as as we
said before that ethical concepts are
actually pseudo concepts that what they
reveal to us is ultimately just an
expression of preference or feeling or
moral sentiment or the attempts to get
other people to feel the same or to
produce action on their part acting as a
sort of disguised command so error is
going to criticize all three of these
main approaches very common in his time
in ethics saying that the the radical
empiricist or a motive isten that he is
developing is superior to them
you